bonsoir galette bencheikh merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
emmanuel macron qui pète donc pour un
islam des lumières comment l'accueil et
vous l'expression n'est pas là et celle
du regretté malek chebel un islam des
lumières ce que j'appelle aussi l islam
de beauté d'intelligence de spiritualité
d'élévation d'humanisme c'est possible
dans notre pays et la france mérite cet
islam là ne veut nous oeuvrons
inlassablement pour que ce soit le cas
et nous nous donnons les moyens pour le
réaliser
parce qu'il a été possible à un moment
donné de l'histoire
il a connu un apogée civilisationnel la
concomitance de trois grands empires l'
empire ottoman lempire safavide empire
moghol rien ne dit qu après la
régression tragique et il y en a eu une
véritablement puisque nous sommes hélas
en crise et c'est une crise qui a assez
duré que depuis paris depuis la france
en europe
la résurgence la réémergence de cet
islam de beauté d'intelligence ne puisse
pas se faire et elle ne se fera pour que
le sang des innocents qui a été versée
l'effusion de sang d'être innocent lors
de ces attaques
abject terroriste du à l'islamisme
pianiste ne soit pas de veine cette
diffusion 100 alors un conseil engage
pour labelliser les imams sera créée en
france
mais la question qu'on se pose c'est
comment faire entrer les imams actuelle
dans ce modèle il existe peut-être d'y
avoir des réticences
c'est au conseil français du culte
musulman de trouver ces critères là
d'admission et on a ce qu'ils sont on ne
peut plus simple c'est avant tout la
maîtrise de la langue nationale de la
langue française des connaissances et
des compétences théologique cultuelle
ne serait-ce que la connaissance de la
théologie classique islamique
et puis son vouloir ramener les choses à
ce que fait la fondation de l'islam de
france parce que nous donnons des
bourses et nous formons pour la partie
civile républicaine culturel laïque
ce complément de formation cultuelle il
faut bien que nos imams puisse
comprendre le fonctionnement des
institutions de la république qui puisse
aussi maîtriser le droit des cultes
qu'ils sachent assumer l'héritage
français l'héritage historique et
culturel de la france j'ai eut même
l'occasion de dire non sans un brin de
provocation
il faut bien que ces iman apprennent la
geste de roland qu'il ne fût pas tendre
vis-à-vis de la tradition religieuse
islamique c'est ça me semble-t-il qui
doit constituer les critères de
l'admission au sein de ce conseil
national des imams je préfère parler de
critères d'admission que que dan de
labellisation j'ai entendu le lille les
l'imam parer aux gros dire de quelle
labellisation s'agit-il
c'est vrai donc c'est une affaire de de
reconnaissance des critères de d'imama
met donc il ya des conditions à réunir
et de ce point de vue là les les imams
de france doivent véritablement avoir la
connaissance requises pour être des
thérapeutes de l'inde pour cette prise
en charge spirituelle et morale de toute
une jeunesse qui ne faut surtout pas
laisser comme une proie facile à des
sermoner doctrinaire à des idéologues à
des aventuriers et surtout ne pas
laisser cette jeunesse aller s'abreuver
sûr
net auprès du cher google 2.0 et
pardonnez moi encore une fois je
reviendrai à ce que nous faisons à la
fondation de l'islam de france est pour
ça que nous avons mis en oeuvre un conte
cus numérique
une sorte d'université digital avec pour
ambition d'être le premier site de
référence francophone afin de de
répondre aux interrogations des
musulmans et des non musulmans sur le
fait islamique et que nous ne laisserons
pas notre jeunesse
allez s'aventurer sur ce qu'ils leur
mire qui leur font miroiter je sais trop
quel destin ici bas ou ailleurs dans un
au delà annoncé comme meilleur et
durable alors l'objectif 1 il est qu'un
il est connu mettre fin d'ici quatre ans
à la présence en france des 300m
étrangers détaché par la turquie le
maroc et l'algérie est ce que ça vous
semble atteignable
en tout cas je pense pour ma part qu'il
est temps d'en finir avec avec le
respect absolu que j'ai pour la dignité
humaine avec cette importation des
images nous avons la possibilité si nous
ne l'avons pas encore nous devons nous
débrouiller pour faire en sorte que nos
imams soient formés dans notre pays il
n'y a aucune raison de continuer à faire
venir certains immeubles ce n'est
peut-être pas la totalité qui vient sans
transition qu avec certaines idées qui
ne vont pas de pair avec l'ambiance
générale avec l'univers social
psychologique français si encore une
fois je ne généralise pas parce que
toute généralisation et allusive
s'ils viennent avec cette idée
la société française est permis et
permissive et dépravé dissolue je ne
vois pas quel va être le sermon quel va
être le prêche qui peuvent tenir aux
dires du haut de leur chaire dont les
mosquées donc il faut bien une
connaissance de le mot est à la mode un
peu de l'écosystème français et de ne
pas encore une fois faire venir des
imams que ce soit du maroc d'algérie au
de turquie particulièrement afin de
d'initiés ou au d'instruire au de guider
ou de conduire un office et la prière en
france
merci beaucoup quand même bencheikh
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france